and perspective simply reminds us to go
to 50 000 feet on a bad day and count
our blessings
perspective simply reminds us that
things could be a lot worse
perspective on a bad day is simply
understanding that we live in a world
where half the world's population lives
on less than two dollars and fifty cents
a day
perspective on a bad day is reminding
yourself that of that persian proverb
which says i cursed the fact i had no
shoes until i saw the man who had no
feet
perspective is such a powerful word
here's a great question
on a bad day to bring on some
perspective
has anyone died here
so perspective is something i really
want you to think about and on a bad day
it will actually allow you to turn the
lead into gold and really pivot
as ernest hemingway noted the world
breaks everyone
and afterward
many are stronger in the broken places
but my question is why
isn't everyone
to me it comes down to the strategies
that you use there really isn't anything
objectively good or bad there isn't
anything that happens to you that can't
be overcome there isn't anything
that could happen to you anything
that when you turn inward you can't find
a reason to overcome you can't find a
way to put those pieces back together
and that becomes your job it becomes
literally up to you whether you're going
to sit and wallow and woe is me because
what happened happened and there's no
way to take it back but how you respond
what you bring to that table whether you
meet fire with fire whether you meet
that adversity with
falling apart becoming weaker in the
areas that broke or you bind them and
mend them and it becomes like a well
that literally
makes you stronger
is a choice
and it's a choice only you get to make
but as stephen hawking said
when you complain
nobody wants to help
you there are many things in your life
you have every reason to complain about
you have every reason to be upset by the
things that have happened to you the
most sinister thing about excuses is
they're
valid
there's a million reasons why you should
be able to give up there's a million
reasons why you shouldn't need to try
that thing that broke you you should be
allowed to just sit on the ground and
here's the thing that's your right you
have every reason to do it
and maybe people won't even think less
of you
but here's the truth
you either become weaker or stronger in
the places that broke and that's a
choice of how you react moving forward
the great news is
the best thing that you can do to become
stronger
is love yourself
and as kamal ravikant said
loving yourself is a practice
people think that it's something that's
gonna feel right that it's gonna feel
natural that you're just gonna turn
inward and there it is the spark of love
and joy for yourself inside yourself the
truth is that's just not the human
experience that's not the way that it
works there's gonna be a voice inside
your head and it's going to
blame you it's gonna say that it's your
fault and no matter how many times
people on the outside tell you that that
is not true that this thing happened to
you that it isn't you it doesn't define
you there will be a voice that's going
to tell you that it does and that's
where you have to fall back on process
that's where you have to realize that
you literally have to practice loving
yourself and that it's okay
that no matter what happens there is
absolutely nothing that invalidates
that you're worthy of your own love
but you've got to practice it you've got
to be willing to do it you've got to be
willing to put in the reps you've got to
know that it's not going to feel right
but you've got to know on the other side
of that is a vision of your life
where you actually do love yourself
because you took the time to say it you
took the time to practice it you took
the time to sit there and feel stupid
and say that you love yourself
and sometimes just putting in the work
is what you need to do to get strong
so put in the work
i'm always prepared
i prepare for what's coming here's the
deal
change is inevitable
so here's what's going to happen no
matter what's going on in your life is
not permanent
everything is going to change
so there's two things you can do with
change
you can react to it or you can
participate in it it's going to change
anyway
so if you keep waiting around you're
gonna have to react to the change and
now you you're behind but if you
participate in the change if you know
the job you have is not gonna last
forever
i'm just telling you
covet proved that already
where you go to work at every day that's
going to change
covett proved that already
your best laid plans
has changed
so what you got to start doing is you
got to start anticipating that it's
going to change and just start living
your life with the preparation for
change
no matter what you're doing you could be
doing more remember that
it's 24 hours in a day
you got to use as many of those hours to
prepare stability for yourself as you
can it's never too late to decide what
you want to do with your life
better late than never right uh at the
end of the day we all want to find
something that we're passionate about we
want to do something that we believe in
that we feel connected to some people
are lucky that they figured out 20 30 40
50 60 who cares when you do it it's kind
of like moving house i used to live in
one neighborhood in new york city and i
fell in love and i moved to a different
neighborhood and i thought oh this new
neighborhood is so much better and i
lived for 10 years in that other
neighborhood within a few months i felt
like this was my neighborhood and it was
great and i've always been doing it
it's kind of like that you know which is
if you find the thing you love
you'll be so consumed and in love with
it it doesn't matter when you do it as
long as you're doing it so definitely
definitely if you don't think you're
doing something you love
definitely look for it no matter how old
you are you'll find it unbelievably
rewarding i promise
you don't need to know where this moment
or where the world is going
you just need to know where you are
going next and one of the things that
has happened uh certainly in the
pandemic but it always happens when
there's any kind of reckoning in your
life
is that when you have something suddenly
happen and your life is fundamentally
changed whether it's a death or somebody
says i don't love you anymore or you're
fired or you find yourself uh with a
scary health diagnosis there is a line
in the sand there is a life before
that happened and then a life after that
moment happened and that line in the
sand that reckoning that happens and it
happens for all of us whether it's
happening for you right now or it has
happened in the past i'm telling you
there is a gift inside of this even the
darkest moments because every single
sudden change in your life that makes
you feel like you've lost control and
you no longer know where you're going
it's like hitting the giant pause button
and if you
lean into the moment
there is a chance for tremendous wisdom
and growth there are things that you can
do right now
in order to take control of where you're
going of what you're thinking about and
you can start to take this moment of
change and you can use it to be able to
take and make an intentional pivot
in the direction
that is meant for you next and one of
the things i want to say about this
moment is look if you're losing loved
ones you are terrified this has made you
lose your job you feel like you're in
that moment where everything you know
you're falling off a cliff you're trying
to pack a parachute you're grieving
and so you got to give yourself space to
grieve the losses that you're feeling
and when you get a little bit of
distance from the grieving and the ways
of grief and fear that you're feeling
start to space out they don't ever leave
you but over time those waves of holy
cow and i don't want this and i can't
handle this and why is this happening to
me
time will start to lessen those waves
you will gather your feet underneath you
again
and you will
absolutely
be stronger and be a better version of
yourself based on this incredible
challenge that you're facing
and i can say that even though you may
be facing a tough time because if you
think about your life you faced
extraordinary challenges and there
hasn't been a single one that hasn't
made you a better and stronger version
of yourself and this moment will be no
different
so i want you to understand that when
you get out of the cycle of grief
this is an enormous reckoning an
enormous opportunity for you to hit the
pause button and for you to start to ask
yourself the question what do i want my
life to look like
because i think too many of us are
sitting here going i can't wait for my
life to get back to normal i can't wait
for this to end i can't wait to things
to go back to normal and in any moment
of reckoning
what happens is there's actually parts
of your old life
that you don't want to go back to
and there is a tremendous amount that
you're learning in this moment that you
need to pause and take in and say okay
based on what i've just learned based on
my old life when i look ahead to my new
life what is it that i want my new life
to look like this next chapter i can
turn to a blank page i can take all this
wisdom all this resilience all this
strength and i can write something new
the reason we all have fears in general
is because we don't know what the
outcomes or the consequences are going
to be on the other side of that behavior
you may have inflated fears about what's
going to happen if you for example quit
your job to start a company or to start
putting content online or to asking that
girl on a date or to asking your boss
for grace whatever you're afraid of the
reason is is because you think that
there are downsides to actually trying
that and so you're afraid to attempt it
because you don't know what's going to
happen and according to prospect theory
and other research from daniel kahneman
all people inflate the fear of loss
we're more afraid of loss than we are of
gain actually
losing hurts more than gaining and so if
you're afraid of something it's because
you think if you try it you may actually
lose something and again according to
prospect theory you probably inflate
those potential losses enormously
now what happens when you actually do
what's called fear testing where you
actually test your fears it's just like
going to the gym you've got to go to the
gym to strengthen your muscles and
you've got to actually like pump weight
eventually you can you can actually lift
way more weight than your former self
and the same thing is true of fear if
you avoid fear all the time then it's
kind of like you can barely lift five
pound weights of fear but if you
actually fear test or fear train
eventually you can face
100 pound fear experiences or a thousand
pound few experiences it's all internal
it's all your ability and your
confidence ability to know that what's
on the other side of your fear is the
development of skills capabilities and
confidence
and so what you do is you fear test you
fear train regularly if there's
something you're afraid of that's
towards your future self that you want
you want to
try it
actually what the research shows as well
in psychology is that the anticipation
of an event is always way
worse or way more potent than the event
itself our imaginations are intense and
so we dread or we come up with all sorts
of worst case scenarios and the fear
itself is what's actually scary fear is
more scary than the actual potential
events we're so afraid of fear that we
avoid it at all costs you can train your
fears in small ways by trying low stakes
things which really won't have that big
of repercussions such as for example
asking for a mentorship or whatever it
is that's a low stakes thing that still
you have a little bit of resistance
towards you immediately try it and
here's what happens is once you actually
attempt the behavior and you get to the
other side of that fear
you get to the other side and you
realize this
the downsides that you were imagining or
inflating are usually not nearly as bad
as you thought once you get to the other
side whether you fail or whether you
failed the situation or whether things
didn't work out it wasn't that bad in
fact it's kind of like asking your boss
for a raise someone might wait for
months and months to do that they may go
in there and ask their boss for a raise
it's a 10 minute conversation they
either get rejected or they get accepted
but either way it really wasn't that bad
and then once you're on that other side
now that you are more clear on the fact
that it wasn't that bad now you're more
clear towards your future so dan
sullivan actually has a four-step model
he calls it his four c's formula and he
says whenever you want something new you
first have to start with commitment
commitment then leads to courage so
you're committing to something that
maybe scares you
then commitment leads to courage which
is that you're trying something outside
your comfort zone or outside your
knowledge base and that's where a lot of
the fear is is the fear of the unknown
fear of uncertainty fear of not knowing
what's gonna happen plus you inflate the
outcomes that you think are gonna be
terrible
once you actually start attempting it
you start realizing it's not that bad
and that's where you start to develop
new capability and confidence there is a
better you
a stronger you
a wiser you a more patient you and more
perfectly prepared you
uh
of literally an ever ready you right now
going for it for the dream that's right
ahead of you and and you haven't lost
any time a dream requires your
protection your dream requires your
protection it's it's it's it's it's
counting on you to protect it it's
counting on you to protect it by not
just
knowing that there's a thing called time
management but living in time management
your dream is saying protect me by not
giving away your yes
can you please
introduce yourself to know now is not a
good time i have some other priorities
your dream is asking for your protection
to eat in such a way that your body is
ready for a marathon when i first wanted
to start speaking and i was a bit now
i'm 24 or 5 and i'm like i want to be a
speaker no one's a speaker there's like
tony robbins jim rome zig zigler les
brown and you just know about them from
over there like you don't really you
know
and i was like i want to do that thing
and so it you know if you think it's a
it's it's a wild wild west right now it
was a wild wild west
uncharted turf 25 years ago and i
remember a couple of friends of mine
giving me a list of reasons
why i can't be a speaker
you can't be a speaker because you gotta
fail in english lisa do you remember
that uh yeah you got a d minus in speech
do you remember that like they had a
list of why i couldn't do it and i said
stop hold on
i'm already
trying to
stop talking myself out of this
like i'm already i'm already in my head
trying to climb over my own doubt please
don't give me yours as well and i
remember asking them i i i then took my
dream
to strangers
i took my dream to strangers who didn't
look like me i took my dream to
strangers who weren't my nationality
i'll be honest i took my dream to
strangers who weren't my gender i took
it was older white men
but i just i just happened to land in
that community and i shared my dreams
sorta sorta and they had the nerves to
uplevel my dream because i was like
oh you just scared me like they uh they
were like that's good but i think you
could do that i was like whoa i didn't
see that
and i knew then because they made my
stomach flip they made my little flies
turn the butterflies turned to bats
right they made me want to stay up at
night and figure out how they made me
uncomfortable and so that's when i
hooked my caboose to their train i got a
second job to pay for my caboose
being hooked to their train and i never
let go 13 years later company built
money made lifestyle change
and i was like huh
i protected the dream
life has no duplicate as jerry jackson
would say and so you want to do life
on your terms you want to do you you
want to live each day as if it were your
last and give it everything you have and
that's what i'm focused on that my 77th
year on the planet
is is to finish strong and to do things
that will
impact my children and my grandchildren
and and my
my
great-grandchildren and live a life that
will outlive me as we look at now where
we are there's a reckoning that's going
on
and
this is an incredible time to
really turn things to your advantage and
there are a lot of people right now are
looking and asking the question what's
next
because life is disruptive
but also in the process
it's transformational because when
there's a disruption you have to
transform yourself to accommodate the
disruptions you don't want to just be a
victim or a witness you want to be
engaged and on top of your game in order
to go to that next level and new york
requires that the world requires that
right now more than ever before i asked
a young man who was taking my bags i
said what's your passion he said my
children he said in a split second
that that grabbed me
because that's where i'm coming from my
children that's my passion of the things
that i do to generate money that's one
thing but my passion is to help my kids
have the tools they need
to live a meaningful
successful impactful life to be an asset
to the world rather than a liability and
i know many of you feel the same way
and so as you look at yourself look at
your goals and look at what do you want
to do how many of you are hungry for
greatness let me see some hearts up in
here up in here
you have greatness in you you have built
in greatness but that greatness it must
be focused on that greatness it must be
cultivated and developed
that greatness it must be called forth
and and as you work on yourself and work
on your dreams and realize that you've
been given the power authority and
dominion to do more than you can ever
begin to imagine you can make a
difference in this world no matter what
you do for a living and really really
hear that you know i get so many
questions from people saying
gosh i feel like what i do just isn't
that important or marie you know what i
want to find a way to make a bigger
impact in the world what should i do
this is what you should do don't just
focus on what you're doing give
attention to how you're doing it because
you have countless opportunities every
single day to change real people's lives
simply by choosing to start infusing
everything you do with some genuine love
and enthusiasm and your humanity and
just watch the difference that it makes
both for you and for everybody around
you i always tell people
you know the people around you they
don't want like presents like things you
know we think they want things you know
what what they want is presence
your full
dance of energy right now with them
right here that's presence
being here now but being here now in
reverence and positivity that that's
what i think we got to work on lots of
people yeah they're good at being here
now and they're being mindful but
they're still kind of in a crappy
attitude what people want from us is
presence that full engagement in the
minute
where we're having that dance of energy
between us that is positive and
reverential meaning we have reverence
for each other we have reverence for our
lives and i'll tell you what if all you
got from this entire session today was
like you know what i need to start
showing up for my family for my team in
the ways that i serve with more presence
that is a dance with the energy of the
moment and that is positive and that has
real reverence i'm telling you what
that's what life's about self mastery to
me from what i've learned from our high
performance studies is full engagement
it's joy it's confidence it's a positive
range of our psychology that makes us
have reverence for the moment so now we
can dance together you know
you ever gone to a party
and you were in a bad mood and you're
just like i'm just not gonna dance
and another time you went to a party and
you were a good mood and you said i'm
gonna dance
well isn't it true you were equally at
both situations you were equally bad at
dancing
you know what i mean it's like i've done
that going to party everyone's dancing
like i'm not having you know i'm not in
the mood another part i'm in the mood
let's dance but i still dance dance
horribly many of you seen it well tens
of thousands of you've seen me dance but
for me
it's it's it's an attitude it's a way
i'm engaging in the moment it's a
presence i'm saying number one let's
begin your planning process with
reverence there is serendipity going on
here there's coincidence going on here
there's blessings going on here there is
literal purpose happening right here
four feet from me in that lens with you
there's a reason that you are here
and if you can connect with that every
day i got up this morning exhausted from
shooting last night and i thought wait
put my feet on the ground like wayne
dyer told me to do said thank you
thank you
thank you
and i reminded myself not oh i gotta go
do this other filming thing here i go
again no no i get to practice my purpose
today
i get to live in purpose i get to show
up in purpose i get to trust that there
is an absolute reason that this day is
happening that there is a a a knowledge
of force and energy something beyond me
that is lined up all of the cards all of
the dominoes that you and i are here
today so if you can not just do that
don't i'm not saying it's just for us
right now i'm saying this for how you
are showing up each day
do you know why life lost some magic in
the last 2019 it wasn't because your
finances it wasn't because of your
health it wasn't because of who's in
your life or who left or who showed up
it wasn't because your team is good it
wasn't because you got paid
no life loses magic because we forget to
bring the magic and experience the magic
intentionally
we hope one day what if you started
living happily right now
as whatever it is you wanted
you know well brenda i want to be
financially free well how would that
feel
what if you walk down the street like a
financially free person i wouldn't walk
into the louis vuittons and put on the
credit card if you know what i'm saying
but what if you just like mentally and
emotionally stepped into how you already
want to feel
you're waiting for three years five
years ten years
to start feeling what you want to feel
what is up with that
you think that more achievements and
more things in 2020 is going to give you
that feeling
let me tell you as somebody who
literally is blessed to coach two
billionaires currently right now
literally working with people on a
day-to-day basis on a week-to-week basis
on their emotions and their lives from
those big fancy people to people you see
in the media to just regular people who
came from places exactly like me
challenged financially
not in a good place in in family or
relationships not in a good opportunity
place and yet
they're able to find that
they're able to connect to that no
matter where you are on the scale of
whatever your ambitions are the question
is can you connect to this moment and
feel like you got it already
that's the secret
that's the magic
having reverence and trust in this
moment
and bringing positive gratitude and
reverence for it i'm so thankful to be
here with you right now i can't believe
you and i get to enter 2020 together we
get to enter a new decade together it
just sounds so freaking cool
i mean i if all i do is put some
enthusiasm on for you today i feel like
we've done a good job because so many
people are like
right now and i'm like here to say
nothing is gonna break that for you that
you're going to achieve outwardly there
is no status money power or fame
there's not if i give you a hundred
thousand new likes on instagram suddenly
you're like yay i enjoy my day no it's
going to be like cotton candy it tastes
good in a second it's gone later
nothing there's no there's no meaning
there there's no calorie there there's
no fulfillment and energy there i know
you know what i'm saying
but i really believe when people start
planning their 2020s they just
their next you know years or decades
it's all about achievement of things
and they think that the achievement of
things is going to give them the
feelings
that are available to them right now
people think the achievement of things
are going to give them the feelings they
want when those feelings are available
right now
i can already walk down the street a
more confident person
in 30 seconds
i don't need to get my certification and
my thing on the wall and and and you
know accolades and fans and followers
and a bigger bank account to be
more confident because what i have to do
is allow more confidence
i have to allow that to happen to say oh
look at these things i've been through
that i
have already experienced that made me
smarter wiser better hey let me pick up
my shoulders a little bit let me put a
smile on my face let me tell myself just
to be confident because i can do that
right now that you can forge your own
emotional reality
and
i mean that's self-mastery now i've got
a really special bonus clip that i think
you're going to enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action for the next week
the science says that when you just
watch a video you get motivated to get
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through on your goals 35
that's not enough that's not enough just
to get motivated believe nation we're
here you're here today matters you're an
action taker
when you commit to a plan of action of
when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else it jumps to 95 chance from 30
something percent to 95 chance of you
following through believe nation we need
to make this happen so question of the
day your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you your
environment is keeping you where you are
your environment has been perfectly
designed to keep you exactly where you
are right now the people you listen to
the media that you consume the habits
that you do daily all of them all of
them are designed to keep you exactly
where you are so if you want to raise
your game if you want to raise your life
you need to raise your environment i've
changed a lot over the course of having
this youtube channel the people who've
known me the best and the longest
especially in the past two to three
years have said evan you've changed a
lot for the better you've evolved you're
more confident you have more more poise
you're a better speaker
you you're pushing the boundaries more
you've changed what happened
how do i get that for myself right
people want it
whenever you are off growing and
learning and evolving
other people they want it they want a
taste of it they want to do it too
because we are not designed to just
photocopy our lives over and over and
over again so how did i get it i paid
more attention to my environment i paid
more attention to my daily routines i
paid more attention to the people that i
hang around with
it's important
so looking at my physical environment
right look at the look at this office
look at the people behind me this all
means something to me looking at the new
design that i've had here below putting
things like my neck braces it's down
below you can't really see it but this
inspires me i walk into this every day
my youtube videos the channel i create
for myself
the the people that i profile i'm
learning from i feel like i have gary
vee in my head i have oprah winfrey in
my ear i've got elon musk telling me
what to do pushing me to try to get
better i hear these people talking about
you have to be courageous you have to be
bold you have to believe in yourself
more and when i feel myself being
nervous about something boom boom boom
boom boom it's a push that i have to do
it
and so i've designed my life i've
designed my environment to help push me
to get to the next step
and it's it's scary
and it should be where am i going next i
don't know i'm still a work in progress
but the more that you are around people
who push you who make you better who
make you want to do more who pull you up
to their level guess what the more
you're gonna get there the alternative
is you're stuck where you are you stick
with your friends you stick with the
media you consume you stick with the
habits that you have and listen if you
love your life awesome if you're good
then you're good then then
don't change anything but if you're not
happy with where you're at if you know
you're capable of more especially for
the entrepreneurs you know you're
capable of more you know you have a gift
you know you're a genius you know what's
in here needs to get out there can have
a huge impact and help a lot of people
if you feel like that's you then you
need to make a drastic change to your
environment
you need to change it because everything
you're doing right now is keeping you on
the path that you're on
maybe there's been some growth if you
look at who you were five years ago
compared to now you've grown if you're
watching this channel you've grown right
you've made some changes but is it
drastic enough like are you proud of
where you're at look at where you've
come from in the past year two years
five years are you proud of where you're
at and are you comfortable with that
same level of growth for the next five
years if not if you think i want more i
want to help faster i want to have a
bigger impact faster quicker
then the fastest way to do it is to
change your environment just cut out the
people who don't serve you sometimes
those are friends that you've had from
kindergarten or high school or
university
you're in the friendship out of
convenience now there's a lot of people
who you might need to let go of you
might need to just let them go they
don't serve you anymore you've you've
walked your parallel path together and
now they've gone out well they probably
just stayed here well you've gone out
here
they don't serve you anymore and it
doesn't mean you have to be a mean
person or cold or rude you're just not
on the same path anymore and a lot of
people fight that because you're worried
about finding new friends or being
around new people and so you stick with
these people who don't serve you anymore
and that's a mistake because they're
keeping you where you're at because
their negativity their complaining their
unwillingness to change their pessimism
their laziness they're not chasing down
goals that that becomes toxic
even if you're trying to be a beacon
even if you're trying to be the person
who pulls everybody up
if all you're doing is trying to pull
other people up and there's nothing
pulling you up
you're going to be limited for life
when i went to the tony robbins event
the second one where he invited me to
come
as his guest
at the end of the first day or second
day you're asked to go do a firewalk and
the whole idea is to do something scary
well i went home
to my airbnb at the time and and i did
the scary thing i didn't i skipped the
fire walk at tony's event to go home and
do the real fire walk which was letting
go of some people that that i had been
around for in some cases a decade plus
that this doesn't serve me anymore i'm
doing this just out of convenience
instead of something that's actually
helping me grow and so i need to shed
this skin so that i can be reborn like
there's this new skin under you that's
trying to grow
right you're trying to become a
butterfly
but you're forced to stay a caterpillar
you don't want that
so you got to let go of the negativity
sometimes that might be family and with
family maybe maybe you should cut out
some of your family members from your
life maybe maybe that's that sounds
drastic but maybe you should
a less drastic version of that is just
don't talk about some things limit
access if you know that career talk is
always going to cause problems with your
family then don't talk about your career
say i don't i'm not talking about that
and stand up for yourself
at what point is this your life this is
your life
your parents your the people around you
they love you they want you to have
success they just they're from a
different era they're a different
generation they don't know what's even
possible right now
what they did if you're 21 their life at
21 was totally different your parents
life when they were your age was totally
different
they don't understand what's available
right now and so even though their
messages is out of love likely like your
parents probably love you
they just don't understand what's
possible
and you can't blame them
this is your fault now you need to
accept responsibility for where you're
at and limit conversations limit
exposure cut out the negativity from
your life it's really hard for a seed to
grow when it's in a toxic waste dump
and that becomes a choice you know a
seed where it gets planted
doesn't really get the choice of where
it gets planted but you you get to
choose you get to change your
environment so choose powerfully and cut
out the negativity from your life if it
is true that your thoughts shape your
life
would you want what you were just
thinking right now to become true for
you
if it's a thought of worry or anger or
hurt or revenge or fear
how do you think this thought will come
back to you
if you hear yourself expressing negative
words of any sort stop in mid-sentence
either rephrase the sentence or just
drop it
you could even say to it out you get to
choose any and all thoughts you wish
these thoughts create your future
experiences
let us stay away from thoughts that
create problems and pain you see my
journey on how to make a difference
was when i was in my 20s and my
assistant i was a pastor i started off
pastoring
she gave me a christmas present i opened
it up and the title it was a book and
the title of the book was the greatest
story
ever told
now i love to read i thought oh my gosh
this is a what a title the greatest
story ever told i with great
anticipation opened up the book and when
i opened up the book all
much to my surprise all the pages were
blank
i looked at her i said well it says the
greatest story ever told
she said turn to the first page i turned
the first page and she had written a
note for me dear john your life is
before you
you fill these paces
with your dreams
with your hopes
with matters of your heart
you write your story
and make it the greatest story
ever told
i took that book home with me
and the next morning i wasn't a writer
at that time at all next morning i
started my i started writing my first
book and this was for me and the first
words on that blank page the first words
i put on that blank page was i want to
make
a difference
because that's exactly what i want to do
i want to make a difference
so as you start to take this make a
difference journey
in our series that we've been doing on
vision and this is the last of the four
as you start your make a difference
journey the first step one is i want to
make
a difference
it begins there it's already in your
heart it was sown in your heart when you
were created
i can still remember being in the fourth
grade and walking across the campus at a
camp meeting my father was an overseer
for about 250 pastors and he was so
greatly loved and he made such a
difference in so many leaders life
and i would hold his hand and in fourth
grade i kind of wanted to go to lunch
and it's only a three minute walk across
the campus but for my dad it was a 30
minute walk
because he'd stop and pray with people
and encourage people and believe in
people and love on people
and i would watch people come and and
just i could tell how much they adored
him and loved him and i'm in the fourth
grade i'm saying
when i get older i want to be just like
my dad i just want to make a difference
i just want to i just want to i want to
add value to people i i really i just
want to make a difference and when you
think about it
when you're making a difference
your spirit is high your your morale is
high
you all of a sudden you feel good about
yourself and you feel good about others
i found that nothing in life
is worthwhile
unless you take risks
nothing
nelson mandela said there is no passion
to be found
playing small
in settling for a life that's less
than the one you're capable of living
now i'm sure in your experiences in
school and applying to college and
picking your major and deciding what you
want to do with life i'm sure people
have told you to make sure you have
something to fall back on make sure you
got something to fall back on honey
but i never understood that concept
having something to fall back on
if i'm going to fall
i don't want to fall back on anything
except my faith
i want to fall forward
i figure at least this way i'll see what
i'm going to hit
fall forward
this is what i mean
reggie jackson struck out 2600 times in
his career the most
in the history of baseball but you don't
hear about the strikeouts people
remember the home runs
fall forward
thomas edison conducted one thousand
failed experiments did you know that i
didn't know that
because the one thousand and first was
the light bulb
fall forward
every failed experiment is one step
closer to success it's good for you to
go take your place in the world have
some ambition have some have a vision
have a goal have a strategy try to try
to be a good person in not not because
it's your duty precisely because that's
the proper way to live we're in danger
of undermining all of that and it's not
good for people one of the things that
i've really learned for example recently
is that there's a or learn to articulate
better is that there's a very tight
relationship between aspiration and
responsibility so let's say
well the first question might be do you
need to aspire to something and the
answer is well yes because you have to
do something okay if you just sit there
you'll die you can't just sit there you
have to go act out in the world okay so
act towards what
well that's whatever your aspiration is
you have to have a name okay well what
should the aim be
well it should be something worth doing
let's say what why do something that you
don't feel is worth doing what do you
think's worth doing well if you watch
other people and you judge when they're
doing something worthwhile usually judge
them positively if you see that they're
taking responsibility at least for
themselves but you want to be completely
useless so other people have to take
care of you that's pretty pathetic and
maybe you could get your act together so
you're taking care of yourself and your
family and maybe you could even do
better than that and take care of
yourself and your family and your
community i know i've gone on stage in
front of 10 000 people
and i thought i should have more
powerpoint i should have more reminders
and i just remember walking out and
saying
i'm here to help rise these people up to
give them capabilities to change their
life it's my vision it's my goal it's my
obligation to use my unique ability to
just help these people and live from my
heart and all i can think about is
changing these people's lives and when i
got out there i wasn't perfect on stage
i wasn't robotic and say the right
things and i didn't have the crisp clear
powerpoint but when i spoke from the
heart it overcame all of that and i get
to be one of the best presenters
wherever i go because i speak from the
heart now you might be saying dean
that's your unique ability and maybe
that is
but i know for you in life there are
circumstances where you have to prepare
you have to do a powerpoint you have to
do a presentation and i want to tell you
passion and from the heart
always always
wins over over prepared and thinking
from the head well let me just ask you
something right now in the in the crazy
presidential race the the gop race you
know ben carson is probably the smartest
guy when it comes to book smart out of
the whole group
and i don't watch the news a lot but i
just read a lot and somebody said this
the other day and it just
it just hit me someone said man ben
carson is probably the smartest guy in
that gop race that's going on whatever
you think of it and i'm not going to
share my opinion but you know what the
guy said when he was done he's like but
we all know the smartest guy never wins
and i was like wow
we all know that the smartest guy never
wins
and what does that mean and it's kind of
what i'm sharing today i'm not saying
you shouldn't be smart i'm sure and so
many of you are probably way smarter
than i am but what i want to tell you is
enthusiasm and passion and living from
your heart to me 100 of the time
outweighs being over prepared and
robotic and trying to think what to say
i hope i'm getting the right message
across today i i've had this question
from so many people how are you so easy
to talk on camera on stage and i i never
have a good answer and i really thought
through it and that's the answer i am
here right now doing this video for you
because each week i want to deliver you
a nugget that you could just place into
your life and make a tiny shift towards
a better life so i don't need a
teleprompter i don't need a script i
didn't i i come here and just want to
deliver and it's coming from my heart
now i have practice i've been on video
for 15 years i've been doing these for
seven eight years
and maybe that's not what you do but
you're still gonna have these
circumstances where you have to talk to
your children talk to your coworkers
talk to your employees and talk to your
employer
and if you get stuck in your head that's
when you get stressed that's when you
get worried that's when you try to
remember what to say and you leave and
go ah why did i say that or why didn't i
say more
what if you can go in and say why am i
going in and live with passion and have
it come from your heart then that's
truly you and you're giving the answers
you're supposed to from the real you not
the facade that sometimes life makes us
wear one of the challenges i think many
people have is really the discernment of
information
it's really difficult to know what's the
truth anymore just because
information is so accessible and i used
to say that in an age of information
ignorance is a choice and and now we
have to confront a whole nother level
and that is
the information that we're getting uh is
it is it actually supporting us or is it
something that really is an incentive to
to cause us to make choices so um for me
i think the biggest challenge has been
just really an awakening to
what kind of information i want to
expose myself to and i and i think it's
now more than ever a challenge for a lot
of people in the world you don't have to
be perfect to inspire others you can
inspire people by how you deal with your
imperfections right don't feel that you
have to have it all know it all to make
an impact you don't you just need a soul
full of desire and compassion right it
was martin luther king who said you
don't need a college degree to serve you
don't need to know how to fill a
sentence to serve all you need is a
heart full of soul right and a heart
full of compassion that's all that's
needed that's what we need to focus on
let's
let's not be limited by feeling we need
other resources apart from love and
compassion to make an impact because we
don't right you actually don't need them
we are going to
um
create
a baseline for ourselves that's based on
intention this was around 1989 when i'd
read gary zhukov's book called the seat
of the soul
and that book was life-changing for me
because in it he talked about the power
of intention
and that
cause and effect
what goes out comes back
is determined
by your intention the energy of your
intention
is what determines your life
people don't think about their intention
they just think about what they want to
do
most people don't think about why they
want to do it
but what's going to come back to you the
energy that's going to come back to you
is the real why of why you did it
and so i then said to my producers we're
not going to do any shows that are not
intentional so don't bring me an idea
unless you have an intention for the
show that you want the outcome to be and
we're going to strive to see if we can
live up to our intentions and so around
the late 80s we started a pre-show to
talk about what the intention was and
then a post show after every single show
to say did we fulfill that intention and
that's about the time i realized this is
bigger than me most of us i'm a
spiritual psychologist and a spiritual
technician that's what i do
and what i learned is we are very loyal
to our family patterns because they're
familiar they're comfortable better the
devil we know than the one we don't know
so even though we don't want to be poor
we'll have a consciousness that'll keep
us poor or keep us sad or keep us in
drama keep us in chaos calm because it's
familiar so that's when i started
studying what i call dntp's dominant
negative thought patterns
and how they manifest and how they
govern our behavior because you know
everything begins with a thought and the
thought creates an attitude and attitude
creates the word and the word creates a
feeling all vice versa to feel and leads
to a thought so i've been studying
dominant negative thought patterns so if
you want to eliminate
family pathology you got to forgive
you got to tell the truth about what's
going on
don't call
a
you know a duck a chicken call a thing a
thing this is what my mother did this is
what my father did this is what they
said this is what it was for me yeah
and you've got to identify your dominant
negative thought pattern if i roughly
took the people i interviewed
and divided them into people
who
really have a sense of worthiness that's
what this comes down to a sense of
worthiness
they have a sense a strong sense of love
and belonging
and folks who struggle for it and folks
who are always wondering if they're good
enough
there was only one variable that
separated the people who have a strong
sense of love and belonging
and have a strong and really struggle
for it and that was the people who have
a strong sense of love and belonging
believe they're worthy of love and
belonging
that's it
they believe they're worthy
and to me the hard part of
the one thing that keeps us out of
connection is our fear that we're not
worthy of connection
was something that personally and
professionally i felt like i needed to
understand better
so what i did
is i
took all of the interviews where i saw
worthiness where i saw people living
that way and just looked at those
what do these people have in common and
i have i have a slight office supply
addiction but that's another talk
so i had a manila notebook a vanilla
folder and i had a sharpie and i was
like what am i going to call this
research and the first words that came
to my mind were wholehearted
these are kind of wholehearted people
living from this deep sense of
worthiness so i wrote at the top of the
manila folder
and i started looking at the data in
fact i did it first in this very four in
a four day
very intensive data analysis where i
went back pulled these interviews pulled
the stories pulled the incidents what's
the what's the theme what's the pattern
my husband left town with the kids um
because i always go into this kind of
jackson pollock crazy thing where i'm
just like writing and going and kind of
just in my researcher mode
and so here's what i found
[Music]
what they had in common was a sense of
courage
and i wanna i wanna i wanna separate
courage and bravery for you for a minute
courage the original definition of
courage when it first came into the
english language it's from the latin
word ker
meaning heart and the original
definition was to tell the story of who
you are with your whole heart
and so these folks had very simply the
courage to be imperfect
they had the compassion
to be kind to themselves first and then
to others because as it turns out we
can't practice compassion with other
people if we can't treat ourselves
kindly
and the last was they had connection
and this was the hard part
as a result of authenticity
they were willing to let go of who they
thought they should be
in order to be who they were
which is you have to absolutely do that
for connection
the other thing that they had in common
was this
they fully embraced vulnerability
they
believed
that what made them vulnerable made them
beautiful
they didn't talk about vulnerability
being comfortable nor did they really
talk about it being excruciating as i
had heard earlier in the shame
interviewing
they just talked about it being
necessary
they talked about the willingness
to say i love you first
the willingness to
do something where there are no
guarantees
the willingness
to breathe through waiting for the
doctor to call after your mammogram
the willing to invest in a relationship
that may or may not work out
they thought this was fundamental we
live in a society where some among us
are prejudiced
right
so there are people who would not
traditionally hire eric thomas
but you will get to a point where nobody
else can do what i do
and your company
the value of your company is greater
than your
racism uh hear what i'm telling you
so you may be racist and not want to
hire an african-american male that looks
like me
but because i'm the best version of
myself in terms of what i do online i
can compete with anybody else who's
doing it the phd
right i need you to hear what he's
saying the phd was very intentional and
deliberate
living a life of character these are all
things that's going to help me out and
then my relationship with god you fit
you through now there's nothing you can
do you stop now you stuck
so it's like you you call everybody else
you might even brought them in and it
didn't change anything so now you're
like all right last resort i got to
bring etn
and then i come in with the anointing
and rip shot
and rip shot
and then you like oh can we get the
retainer i'm like
we could have you could have started
with me
right so i'm telling you what he's
telling me is the truth i'm not saying
oh i can't believe they're still racist
people in 2019 that has nothing to do
with me
that's not my fight
my fight is being the best version of
eric thomas that's what i can control i
can't control industries i can't control
what people think or say but what i can
control is eric thomas and so i'm
telling you what he's saying is real
because you're like but i gotta no you
don't
you don't you still in your mind when he
was saying it's like but you don't get
it i gotta and they don't no
no
you just need to get to that place
where you are strong and when you go in
you want some jedi mind trick stuff if
you're self-aware you don't
try to do things you can't do
you focus on things you do like
you don't try to be something you're not
if you have self-esteem you're not
scared to put it out the content the
video the picture of the audio
because you're not worried if
sallypants49 thinks you're ugly you're
not worried that rick thompson from a
competitive company says you're stupid
you're just not worried you're not
worried that you have bags under your
eyes or you're overweight or you're
losing your hair you're just not worried
you're you're focused on your
self-esteem you're focused on yourself
you're focused on your self-awareness
which puts you in a position to succeed
and so all of you one of the worst not
worst one of the challenging times in my
career was around 2012 when people all
wanted to be like me and i'm a very very
over-the-top high-energy personality
who's very very comfortable on video and
that is just not going to be the case
for everybody and i tell everybody and
it took me a while to get to this good
answer which i think has helped people
listen my friends if you're watching
this right now and be like okay i see
what gary's setting up he's going to ask
me to start producing a lot more content
that's the answer by the way
well i don't want to do video well i'm
like good news sarah you don't have to
do video
you might for example i'm a terrible
writer if i was a great writer
i'd be writing a lot more
because writing on linkedin crushes as a
matter of fact my team loves when i i
write all the copy on my instagram posts
right all of them everyone every post in
my life
and they get pumped when i get motivated
and like write a real good one because
we know the post does better copy is the
most underrated thing in social media
today it drives so much of the success
of the picture in the video so
by the way you might be an audio you
might be a talker but you're insecure
about your visual of how you look or the
camera makes you freeze but you're great
with talking so good there's now
clubhouse an incredible app you can go
and be a thought leader in there's just
recording audio and posting that on your
linkedin
linkedin for this group knowing who's in
the room
is equivalent to what facebook was
in 2012.
that will lead to incredible financial
and emotional
success to those in here that heed the
call that i'm yelling today period end
of story i could not be more passionate
about everybody here getting very
serious
and then what you put out
is up to you you know my recommendation
is that it brings value to people
whether it's entertaining whether it's
informational but i also believe that
stories stories are
easier for people this is something that
i'm going to start talking a lot about a
lot more about
i think stories just stories like life
lessons grandma told me and then if
you're good at and i've already talked
brought this up i'm going to bring it up
again because i'm trying to help
everybody here give you some training
wheels
if you say hi i'm karen i'm a sales lead
at this company i this is for my team
but honestly this is for the broader
world because all you sales leaders i
know how it is
you know when i was nine my grandmother
took me to a girl scouts event and sarah
johnson did this and my grandma i did
this and grandma told me to do that and
then i did this and me and sarah johnson
were best friends in high school and
that's ironic because i had a big tiff
between carl and carla recently on my
team and i did this like my grandma did
that and now they just closed the
biggest account together that story
that should come very natural and by the
way you don't need to call out carl and
carla right because that's active you're
in the world right now you can be two
people on my team just think about how
easy that is
for what everyone's struggling with
which is well what do i post
what do i post is grounded in lack of
self-esteem and lack of strategy
period
and so
i'm here today to
build your self-esteem
and not in a delusional way i'm just
trying to encourage you to realize how
real this is because the content
creators that build awareness
and audiences will have the leverage in
business whether it's a small narrow
world and by the way this is a small
narrow sector most of the business
people on this call in this thing that's
great actually
the reality is that's great because then
you run a couple dollars in ads on
linkedin against targets of companies
that are in your sector and you're
getting exactly who you want
in a lily pond
a lily doubles its growth every day
and so if i was gonna tell you this pond
right here has one lily in it and it
will take 30 days for the lilies to
cover the entire pond
what day would the lilies cover half the
pond
now most people the first thought that
you have is 15 days
no
that's the problem that's why you have
questions like i can't find my niche i
don't know my purpose
why
it's because in 30 days on day 29
is when the lily pond is halfway covered
the next day it will be fully colored
the scary thing is on day 28 two days
it's only a quarter cupboard
only a quarter cupboard two days before
so you're working day one through 28
not seeing
hardly any increase
any revelation of niche or experience or
spectrum got to have faith you've got to
have faith in what you're doing by
enjoying find the light the love and the
lessons and what you're doing and be
able to do it every single day so you
get the doubling effect of the lilies so
that yes you get to day number 28 from
day number 29 and especially day number
30. and guess what's so fun about that
in day 31 you need two pawns and in day
32 you need four pawns my dream
is to empower over a billion people to
be happy that's a pretty big dream
people laughed at me
and that when i started i had the same
question how am i actually going to do
this right i know the impact of it and
i know you know that it would change the
world but now then i said oh my god am i
saying i can change the whole world
empowering over a billion people to
create a collective consciousness and
then i started thinking about it and
saying well what do i need to do to get
started you know what i need to do i
need to empower one person to be happy
then i said to myself okay can i teach
that one person to teach somebody else
because now i get that faith going the
faith of what i want then i say to
myself can i do it one more time can i
teach one person to teach one person to
teach one empowering one person to
empower one person to empower one person
took me years but once i got there now i
connected the dots backwards and said i
just got to do that a thousand more
times i freed myself into moments of
doubt not minutes about days not weeks
not months not years i only have moments
of doubts now but you gotta enjoy the
consistent persistent pursuit figure out
the math of what you want and let's go
inch by inch
let's scale it out with the calculator
of faith exponentially grow into the
expansive being that you are everybody
out there you can't out-ask it i'll
dream it i'll believe it out abundance
it don't doubt it you can't do it so
stick to the math and do the best that
you can to get where you want to be i
have zero anger
i'm a passionate guy so i but i get it
though sure the way i talked when i come
across
i'm an aggressive guy
because that's what it takes to like if
you walk into a situation
into a fight i'm not saying be so
aggressive that you're that you're so
aggressive that you're making bad moves
sure
but if you don't have a little flame
burn in you knowing that i might get hit
real hard and when i get hit
i have to attack i have to i have to
have to bring i can't get knocked out
right right you have to have that
mentality
of when i went to hell week
i knew i was gonna get broken
i had to have an internal flame in me
that could never be
it couldn't be kindly
killing you put the water kill me that's
south right yeah
i had to be a
tree that is burning hard it's burning
for a long time and that's what i became
man so it's not anger anger can't
sustain you for a long period of time
because once you get a situation try
trust me i tried it before
you get a real hard situation
and you're miserable
miserable
that anger is gone
what comes up is real
the real feeling of who you are and
where you're at you don't want to care
about them people who make fun of you in
high school or your dad being the [ __ ]
out of you because now
you're you become selfish
you're like let's say you're in hell we
get that cold [ __ ] waters 50 degrees
and you're and your balls in your mouth
right now you're thinking oh dude like
your mind i'm thinking those kids in
high school
bullied me or my hands at least you're
worried no you're thinking
so let anger confuse you for so long
there has to be something so deep in you
that drives you so what really does it
for me
is i know what we're capable of
and i know that most human beings
aren't willing to go
where i am
and that's a very very dangerous thing
i'm not saying i'm bearing anybody else
everybody has this talent sure it's not
a talent it's just realizing that we
stop way short of our true potential how
do you make it sustainable so you
continue to want that throughout well if
you want to break through not just a
little change you know you can change
laterally you know you can go from being
pissed off to frustrated
right doesn't help much right but if you
really want to change most people are
trying to change they want to lose
weight they want to make money they go
how do i do it they look for the
strategy but i like all three of you to
think of three s's strategies where most
people go first like how do i do it but
how hard is it really truly to be fit
and have energy it's not that complex
it's not like reserved for the one
percent or expensive to learn you have
to interrupt you have to hide from the
answers to those things the real problem
is the second s story see the reason the
person is making progress they may not
know what to do sometimes that's true
but some don't know what to do and they
don't do what they know that's most
people and so why they have a story that
says it's a set of beliefs they tell
themselves over and again i've tried
everything or if they're single all the
good ones are gone you know you know
whatever the story is and if you tell
yourself a story over and over again you
know hitler used to say tell a story big
enough loud enough long enough people
believe you well we're hitler to
ourselves we convince ourselves the
thing we really need that was
you always come up with lousy story when
you're in a lousy state yeah and so the
number one thing i show people do is how
to change their emotional state when
you're feeling tired or frustrated when
you learn how to change your body so
that you really feel excited and isn't
fake when you learn how to change your
biochemistry which is what i teach
people to do when for example when
you're in love when you when you're
upset with someone do you ever notice
how you can now remember everything that
they've ever done that ever upset you
okay
and when you're in love when you're
telling love everybody make the sound of
being a love try it
oh it's been a while for some of you
clearly let's try it again out of your
mind and love you can't stop thinking
about the person make the sound how that
feels go for it everybody
[Applause]
i will work on that
but when you're in love what's wrong
with life
what's wrong with anything when you're
loving oh we have no money who cares
we're in love right
so your emotional state controls the
story you have about your life and then
your story determines whether you find a
strategy or even if you know the
strategy whether you really do it or not
when people say i tried what they're
really telling me is i have a story that
says i should try this but it's really
not going to work so i give it a half
weird attempt and it didn't work and i
can tell people i tried what you really
got to do is learn to change your
emotion your state
change your story and then you can find
the strategy or you can make the
strategy to work weight loss industry
field called the fat set point
and every brain has a fat set point and
it basically states that you have a set
point just like a thermostat that's
programmed in a room to have a set point
we have fat set points we have financial
set points we have relationship set
points we have these
set points that we become accustomed to
achieving and then all of the supporting
evidence the stories the themes the plot
lines the perceptions and behaviors all
must match the set point
and so you can ask yourself two
questions number one is how did that set
point get there and then how do i change
it right so how it got there is through
all of your conditioning through what
you've read what you've done what you've
experienced what you've been told what
you've seen all of that has created
your financial set point based on your
story
and so the first thing to recognize is
the set point can be changed
and the question is how
right and that's the million dollar
question so number one what drives
behavior more than anything else it's
not skill it's not knowledge skill and
knowledge is potential power but what
does drive behavior or anything else is
beliefs
and so if there is a belief
in the brain that says yes you know i
think i'm capable of achieving double my
income would just use double my income
but there's another
belief that opposes that that causes
what we
we know is as neural
dissonance so it creates a chaotic
vibration in the brain between the
conscious and non-conscious mind so the
key is to get alignment between the new
goal which is a conscious pattern of
thought that you can choose in an
instant and the non-conscious
part of the brain around that goal
so how do you develop a belief right so
it's a pattern so
if i gave you a sentence
and you said that sentence one time you
probably agree to be a sentence like
when i was like hearing a line in a song
one time but if you heard a line in a
song
repeatedly 20 30 40 50 times and you had
other associations with that to
reinforce that pattern then you would
start to develop a non-conscious pattern
through that so we know that using let's
say visualization you're actually
bypassing the conscious mind and you're
accessing
the visual cortex of the brain it's a
non-conscious process the visual
processor
and so if we take words and we affirm
them and we feel them and we visualize
and repeat them 100 200 500 000 times
now we start to create a pattern at the
non-conscious level that basically
reinforces a conscious desire if you
land it all back up i walk into cottage
eight and it's before school and there's
ten boys all eight nine and ten years
old running around getting ready for
school and right when i walked in they
looked at me all of them in the family
room and kids that come from abuse of
any type have different eyes than kids
who don't and in that minute my life
changed because these boys wanted
someone to love them believe in them
coach them tell them how to live their
life better and i started coaching
people and believing in people and
loving people and giving to people in
that moment involuntarily my whole life
changed in that instant for this reason
i fell in love with giving i fell in
love with being a giver everything you
want to do to get to the next level
listen to me i don't have a business
talk today if you could identify how you
could give more give more of your love
give more of your belief give more of
your time give more of your effort give
more of your energy you will go to the
next level if you're not feeling great
about yourself or where your life is
right now the pathway out of that is
giving
it will always be giving is everybody
with me on that say yes
i i promise you
i felt so good and i believe the pathway
you were born to do something great
because it's to give something something
big and something small it might be as
small as a prayer that you just whisper
for somebody in the room they never know
you gave them it's a hug it's i believe
in you it's time it's it's whatever it
is it's what can i give what can i give
if you want to learn from dr joe
dispenza on how to attract anything you
want in your life check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there the person has to use those
tools
to get them into the emotional state
for them to feel like it's already
happened now think about this